so Harry the Home Office says it's
irresponsible to have these kind of
services where no one could get in there
and to end encryption do you agree the
fact is it's not even possible to
prevent an to end encryption it is a
technology that exists now it's not just
in whatsapp it's in telegram it's in
signal it's in a number of a number of
messaging communications and you can't
prevent it so what what could the
government do they could potentially
demand access to some of the metadata
behind it but I don't think there is a
way literally that they could this is
the so-called backdoor exactly I mean
there isn't really a way to have
backdoor access to to end-to-end
encryption because the the key changes
every message so um it's it's a choice
you have to find another way of
accessing it and that would be
potentially through accessing the phone
or accessing as I say the metadata that
Facebook would have but that would only
tell you who the person is messaged at a
certain time right so the way into it
then necessary I mean the the WikiLeaks
revelations for example revealed that
the CIA you can already intercept
devices before a message has even gone
on to what's what's up so if they can do
it why can't the UK intelligence
services well look they may be doing it
there are ways to AK into phones and you
know hacking is is an arms race right so
I'm obviously phones are now the key
means of communication and hackers are
finding ways to sort of access people's
phones so if they can do it so can the
the security services so yes if you can
access your phone if I can access your
phone from GCHQ potentially sort of hack
into it then I might be able to see the
messages because they're in the phone
they haven't been encrypted at that
point if I'm not you're mine my wife
telling me what to bring home from the
shops tonight mainly but so this the
back this backdoor thing I mean what's
the risk there potentially if there is a
backdoor then the likes are the Russians
or the Chinese or anyone else could hack
into it as well exactly I mean you know
we're in an answer ace if if if you if
you open backdoors then you're just
giving a backdoor to to much more
sophisticated hackers this is a multi
multi-billion dollar hacking industry
and we would be making ourselves much
more than
so what would be the consequences then
if amber rod gets her way presumably
whatsapp and Facebook become a whole lot
less investable I mean honestly I don't
see that happening
I mean clearly if the word terrorist
worried about that then they would just
switch to another messaging applications
it would have very little times will
benefit in terms of fighting terrorism
and for the users of Facebook and
whatsapp frankly knowing that all your
messages could be read by Facebook which
is what you'd have to do if you ended
end-to-end encryption that's not very
comfortable either because you know how
are they using that message those
messages to target me notwithstanding
that though Harry I mean the the optics
of this are pretty terrible for Facebook
aren't they yes again I mean they're not
a company with a good image of the best
of times but I mean this looks like
they're putting the nation's security at
risk almost I think like they're
providing a messaging platform that's
that's used by a billion people some of
those messages are good some are ill I
mean do we ban the telephone because the
telephone is being used as part of
terrorism I'm afraid terrorism is you
know it was horrible what happened last
week and I cycle over Westminster Bridge
every morning and you know so it's very
close to home but at the same time I
cycled over this morning and you know
it's a risk that I'm afraid we have to
take I'd much rather run that risk than
then have effectively people sort of
spying on me all right Harry Briggs from
bgf ventures good to see you thanks for
coming in